I'm a bit of a history buff especially
for American history and I was
I love the Kennedy administration in the
Cold War period especially and I was
reading a brilliant biography that
Robert dalek wrote an unfinished life
and in the section about Cuba there was
a story about this guy called James
Donovan who had been sent to Cuba to
negotiate for the release of 1500
servicemen that had been caught after
the Bay of Pigs and in the book there
was a little footnote right at the
bottom that said Donovan came to
prominence for arranging a spy swap
between Rudolf Abel and an American
pilot Gary Powers it was just a tiny
little mention and I just thought this
is crazy who is this guy like Kennedy
JFK sent him to negotiate with Castro
prior to that he's done a spy swap I've
never heard of this man who is he and I
started to piece together through the
New York Times archive and through the
the kennedy Presidential Library various
different sources and realized that this
was a remarkable story that never been
told of a really incredible hero you
know an American hero that just had gone
kind of unnoticed Tom Hanks is
extraordinary in the film and he's very
recessive visiting Stephen it very much
uses sort of his every guy Ness to his
advantage in these negotiations I think
he's probably for me anyway it less
every guy in this movie that he has been
in many of the movies he's made before
and I always say that because there's
something knowing Tom as well as I do
there's something about this character
that Tom really respected and the fact
that you know he was going to be a
badass and when Tom saw the movie he
said he called me up I wasn't with him
when he saw it he saw the my cut my
director's cut and he said wow I can't
believe how badass I am in this movie
and he said I've never been badass
before maybe a little bit and Road to
Perdition but no Donovan's really a
badass and and and I think he was saying
that because he he made he presented
such focused arguments and his arguments
were all
reasonable you know the whole
two-for-one argument I guess he'd like
to do things in multiples because he got
nine thousand people out of Cuba were
supposed to get thirteen fifteen hundred
but but I just found Tom to really find
this guy very quickly and the very first
thing we shot for your first thing we
shot in the movie is the first scene
that Tom appears in that was our first
day of shooting with Tom were as some
insurance you know representing the
insurance company he's trying to settle
a case and not had the case you know
reopened to make more settlements so
he's not the nicest guy that world and
he's in an occupation which is a little
bit questionable anyway and and as he
started as he starts the scene when we
finished shooting that day Tom said I
know who James Donovan is and for him
that that was the precedent that
informed him how to play James Donovan
we shot half the movie here in New York
and then half the movie in germinal
Germany nominally but you know East
Berlin of the early 1960s isn't around
anymore when you walk around Berlin it's
it's kind of changed a bit so we went
actually further afield and went into
Poland and there's a town and in western
Poland that that really provided kind of
a backbone for the the East Berlin
sections of the film and so finding that
was a bit of an exploration and then
once we kind of locked in on that that
was really the key to the whole thing
and then we work backwards into into
everything else what was some of your
costume design choices in making sure
that Tom and the rest of the film had a
fit apiece the direction in the script
were so clear and so precise and we had
so much incredible research photographic
research then I thought my job was
fairly easy
other than organizational how to how to
represent that reality we attacked the
research ferociously that was the
biggest challenge to gather all the
pieces and then to construct teams in
all the countries where we were filming
and prepare all the materials we felt
very much from reality
and as all the pieces of the film were
coming together it was so much driven by
reality and resonated reality that my
job was just to fit within the frame and
not to not to let's talk about the
production design of the bridge itself
and checkpoint charlie which I have
always long romanticized checkpoint
charlie but there is also a simplicity
to checkpoint charlie it was not wasn't
this big amazing place it was sort of
just this little Street few shops on the
sides right I mean really it's it's a
little white guard shack in the middle
of a road and that's that's what it is
but but but the images of it are very
iconic and so we try to pull the really
important things that the sign that says
no stare and the sign of the pelican inc
sign and you know and get the get the
places that we're really they're in the
right position so that they they kind of
show up in the photographs the same way
so you you have your memories triggered
of it but but yeah it's it's a guard
shack and in a road really I mean that's
that's what that's what it is and what
about the bridge itself yeah yeah the
bridge is the bridge is the bridge I
mean we went there and and it in it and
it's still standing and it's and it is
amazingly right near babbles Berg which
was which was where our construction
base was and so we were building all
this stuff and bringing it right out to
the bridge and it it's as if as if we
had planned that but it but it was just
an incredible accident that it was that
way but it but it was great to be on the
actual spot where this event occurred
was a pretty special thing and the
bridge still has the line right down the
center
dividing East Berlin from West Berlin
east and west the line is still there
and and the other thing that's
irrelevant to the story we presented but
there were two Holocaust analogies to
this story the first being that Vance a
were the architects of the Holocaust
first met to to figure out how to you
know kill six million Jews and and maybe
more and then the other thing was that
Donovan himself along with John Ford the
great director and George Stevens the
great director
they made a documentary
the three of them that that James
Donovan was one of the producers of and
when he was the legal supervisor of this
entire documentary where they presented
visual evidence of eleven death camps
and showed it at the trials at the
Nuremberg war crime trials and pretty
much that's all she wrote for the
defendants shows up in these amazing is
like zelich shows up in these amazing
moments in history when he's sort of not
expecting someone like that there that's
my slight mention when the head of the
Bar Association meets with waters and
and Donovan to asked him if he would do
this job but it's just mentioned he was
a prosecutor at Nuremberg
Stephen to wrap up you have an amazing
story about how when you were teenager
and your father was in line in the
Soviet Union correct and let's talk
about that woman well my dad my dad was
never communist and but my dad was a
very brave man like Donovan and I think
in 1960 General Electric where my dad
worked where we lived in Phoenix Arizona
asked for volunteers five project
managers and electrical engineers to
travel to Moscow on a three-week foreign
exchange so three five Soviet engineers
would come to Arizona and and my dad and
four others would go to Moscow and it
was all on a voluntary basis and my dad
volunteered to do it I got very upset
and so did my sisters and my mom got
really upset because we thought he was
gonna never get out from behind the Iron
Curtain but he just kept saying to me he
kept saying the problem is we're always
talking about dropping nuclear bombs on
each other's countries and people just
aren't talking anymore we need to we
need to have a conversation we need to
talk talking solves all problems my dad
went over there on principle and when he
got over there Gary Powers has been shot
down about a month before and the
Russians had put all of the pieces of
the u2 on display in a building
including the helmet Gary wore and the
flight suit and my dad stood in a long
line everything in Russia in those days
was along a line you know weddings tombs
three hours this was like an hour and a
half to go see the pieces of the the
remains of the YouTube my dad was in the
back of the line and a military man
approached
with some plainclothes people behind
nest ask to see their passports and
that's always scary and they had
actually they had to actually offer
their passports and while this military
man had the five passports in his hand
he cooked a finger and said follow me my
dad speak some Russian and they all went
to the front of the line and got cuts
really and got to see the YouTube in
front of all those other Russians who
were really pissed off because these
Americans are getting cuts but when they
got to their wreckage the colonel or the
officer got really upset and started
shaking his fist and he pointed at the
u2 and he yelled in English look what
your country is doing to us he said that
like three times look what your country
is doing to us and I said to my dentist
said were you terrified of what were you
thinking my dad said well I was watching
his hand with the passports in them I
just kept watching the passports until
we got the back so my dad took all these
pictures and I had never seen the
pictures as a child my dad took pictures
of it so when I gave my dad Matt script
and told him he's almost 99 years old
he's in great shape and I told him um
you know what the movie I'm making next
I said will you read the script so my
dad read the script and after he
finished reading the script which you
really liked a lot he said oh you got to
see these pictures did I ever show these
to you Steve and he pulls him to the
Jordan and he brings out his Kodachrome
slideshow the kind he put in the slide
projector and there are these four shots
of the YouTube and the flight suit in
the helmet which I had not seen until I
got involved in your script